touchdown
worth it Super Ball we were here in
Minneapolis Minnesota bringing you a
very special edition of worth it
celebrating the ultimate gameday food
eating experience when I tried three of
the best gameday food at three
drastically different price points to
find out which one is the most worth it
at its price we've made it to Minnesota
satyam Vikings were in a minivan and
we're in Minnesota in Minneapolis
Minnie's all around so we are on our way
right now into a brand new restaurant
they just hit their one-year anniversary
got Pajarito we're gonna try one of
these staple gameday foods hot cheesy
dip oh yeah I'm techno stanishev and
partner Steeve st chef and partner at
pottery co but we do our take on Mexican
cuisine contemporary neighborhoodie
foods and we take the traditional
flavors ingredients do our own
techniques to them we make all our
tortillas in-house for all our tacos you
do 6 salsas everything else from scratch
we wanted to be a place where people
from you know around here could come and
hang on just have a good time and feel
welcome so we're doing gameday food
today we'll be doing the queso fundido
which is kind of just a molten cheese
dip but we start off with the bechamel
which is just flour and butter milk salt
and pepper we kind of cooked that till
it thickens a little bit the biggest
thing is cooking the bechamel sauce long
enough to give the cheese some of the
grab on - we like to use Monterey Jack
cheese where it's a little more fat
content you could get too much of breaks
and if they're not the right consistency
we we start them over cook it in our
we'll get so nice and golden-brown and
gooey and delicious green chorizo served
on top made with fresh chilies parsley
cilantro so it's nice and green a little
fresher tasting a little more kind of
bite to it some roasted jalapeno and
green onions and then just flour
tortillas nice or a Minnesota beer
companies supporting our local Latino
communities awesome Cheers
that's good oh the texture oh yeah it's
like TV advertising levels of cheese
whoa the Super Bowl the cheese the queso
is so on point here it's got to be the
right texture the right hug temperature
the right flavor it's writing all of
those for me when you see this case
where you're like oh this is gonna be a
gutbuster but it is surprisingly like
it's not that heavy I don't know it's
it's this wonderful kind of naturally
melty consistency that's what I want in
gameday food the flour tortillas are so
soft Adam you've stopped hands don't you
and others really stop hands right like
creepy soft I love how thick it is cuz
it really can hold as much case law as
you want it to 30s are awesome because
they're both plates and food that is an
excellent observation this is really
melting my minds melting the cheese and
it's melting my mind so it wasn't much
of a dip after all but still that would
make an excellent game danger now we're
on our way to a different part of town
fat town back to town to the fact on top
of all day it is estimated that
Americans eat 2400 calories during the
game alone oh man yeah I mean the Super
Bowl like Thanksgiving or Christmas is
one of those days where calories don't
exist anymore next up we'll go into
revival to eat some fried chicken I
don't need any reviving after that case
oh but I will eat the fried chicken
I'm chef Thomas Famer I'm the chef and
owner of revival
what really makes revivals fried chicken
special is that we recreate the time and
temperature and the processes of how
fried chicken is cooked stovetop in a
southern home it's the center of our
food but we also celebrate Andrew from
all over the Carolinas especially where
I grew up what brought you to open a
southern style restaurant here in
Minnesota well I mean it gets cold here
when people come here they come as a
family they come to eat food that
nourishes them in their soul and really
brings people together what we're gonna
do is a very simple southern style fried
chicken that gets eason marinated in
buttermilk and then it gets pulled out
of the buttermilk into a seasoned flour
as you bring it into the flour that
motion and that coating it helps develop
all those great textures so we're really
developing crust that sticks to the
chicken and then we're gonna cook it
nice and slow like fried chicken should
be buttermilk when it's cold it hits the
fryer it expands and it creates all
those wonderful textures and crunchy
bits that we like perfect fried chicken
should look like a bunch of Golden
Retriever puppies it's got to have that
really rich golden color
a Tennessee hot we really wanted to
design our own blend and this is mainly
chili powders and very hot peppers that
are blended with lard Oh what put the
chicken into that after you fry it that
oil soaks it because it's fat based it's
still crunchy because you're not
introducing any moisture as you get
through that piece of chicken and that
spice just gonna build I mean you're
sweating there's no way around that what
really connects this southern food to
Minnesota's this is really one of the
classic samples of true American home
cooking there is a sparkling wine that
was made specifically to balance with
this fried chicken it's not fried
chicken flavor plate a fried chicken and
delightful glass of sparkling wine
Cheers sparkling very pleasant all right
you love this motion don't you this this
is what a quarterback dodge before they
get there oh yeah when he's like give me
a kidney ah oh that light to the touch
here's
instant tears Wow is it from the spice
is it from the joy I don't know
doesn't matter I don't think I've ever
had a crust this good
remember those a fried chicken that my
mom made when I was like nine and this
just like instantly brought me to that
moment you're doing this alive oh yeah
oh yeah that's how you know it's good is
my mouth red
[Music]
breakup biscuit and half for us please
is it good
oh that biscuit smell
[Music]
hmm I thought bids on the Magnum cheese
yo you got to get the crust this place
in cross man they've really figured it
out
whoa I know there are the people that
can't believe that that's hot enough we
developed a sauce that we call poultry
guys the poultry guys is a sauce made
from ghost peppers and golden raisins it
is insanely hot it doesn't look that
antagonizing see on the other side oh my
god whoa I just felt it like come over
the back of my head like a hood toting
the camera like I'm going through some
kind of experience Adam it's not that
bad
instantly feel dizzy like all the little
capillaries in my scalp open up Adam if
you finish that I bought you that
thousands in the middle of Eve I'll eat
that
[Music]
[Music]
we're on a lake right now is it Lake
whoa they have this cool deal here
in a local ice-cream place the colder it
is outside the less expensive your ice
cream is just 20 percent off two degrees
it's colder outside than it is in the
ice cream freezer I thought this is
gonna be a good idea
calm down our tongues from that flaming
hot poultry guys guys but can a fact we
just keep a revival and Thomas actually
once fed the Minnesota Vikings after a
victory they had he served 300 pieces of
fried chicken 40 pounds of bacon cheese
24 pounds of evidence a gallon of whoa
hey Grady 200 biscuits 70 pounds of
smoked brisket beef emailed a barbecue
cold shoulder at 30 pounds a barbecue
fork belly of 10 tons of hot lays 24
pounds of collard greens one gallon each
other falling sauces viola coughed it
must've got a piece off and brisket
thought I've seen football there's some
big boys playing that sport I'm feeling
worth it
there's some big boys again the camera
talking about you Adam that's right
okay so the final spot we're going to is
ciao girls killer catering they're gonna
be catering a feast for the ultimate
Super Bowl party at our place that we
learn in here in Minneapolis I did it's
colder guys it's so cold here hi I'm
Heidi and Irak i am amy Lynn Brown and
we're here at our headquarters in
Northeast Minneapolis we are a catering
company that focuses on local and
organic but we also like to make food
that's really beautiful and approachable
started with the two of us doing
everything and it's grown to a company
of 150 so super bowls being held here in
Minneapolis we want to have an amazing
feast what are we gonna be having today
some of our favorites that we serve here
have Minnesota origins
we're gonna start with the Gerhardt's
nosh butter classic German sausages
sauerkraut featuring Gerhardt's brats
which is a local and family-owned
sausage maker and Aki's pretzels they
make beautiful big soft pretzels hot
crab Catan big woods blue canapes sweet
potato Peppadew bacon-wrapped water
chestnuts and dates we're also serving
cheese balls like you eat at Christmas
in the Midwest and the south where I'm
from
super-fun Brett
DRO so we thought to do two or three
different small ones we have another one
that is [ __ ] Mary seasons a Bloody
Mary cheeseball we've got it one is
beautiful it's shaped like a pine cone
and then for dinner we'll have spinach
and roasted beet salad bacon and sweet
potato hash mashed potatoes and
porchetta which is an Italian pork loin
that's been sliced and rolled out it was
brought to Minnesota by Italian
immigrants who came to work on the Iron
Range and then we coat that in fennel
paprika garlic rolled back up and sliced
it's a regional favorite it's a regional
northern Minnesota for this event we're
gonna come and set it up put it on
display and then we'll leave so you can
enjoy personal experience oh yeah this
is how it's done is it is this game day
or Game of Thrones day because I feel
like I'm in a medieval feast right game
day for me was home right sneaking down
at night watching Sunday Night Football
nibbling on a piece of cheese from the
fridge you have garyun sausage we have
this smoked cheese stuffed sausage just
gonna take some blue öyster extra Cheers
[Music]
mmm sausage is a very football game eat
food I don't know why that reminded me
oh you know when like in football they
always just slap each other on the butts
already meeting British sausage II I've
been I in this guy bacon-wrapped water
chestnuts and dates coated in a tangy
barbecue chili sauce it looks like a
greasy little football the perfect game
David
Oh hmm Square it a little bit big woods
blue canopy blue cheese honey when a
bite-sized biscuit topped with almonds
and roasted grape what what I eat
wait hey no one pepper time sweet and
spicy pickled peppers stuffed with
seasoned sweet potato no way yes way
oh man I bet a Peppadew is gonna be
great with all those sausage I think you
just want to eat more sausages cheesy
juicy meaty sausage sweet and spicy
pickled pepper feel like I'm writing a
poem here my mouth none of the cheese
board I'm so delighted by just the
phrase cheese balls
read a book cheese like this is luxury
it's true when you go cheese party and
you got a slice through the cheese yeah
if I come to your house no not making
slicing cheese please
I think the cheese ball just has a
marketing issue they were called like
cheese domes no need we can respect this
is the focal point of the cheese board
designed to look like a pinecone that's
the ball that's the one okay this one
don't see one this one and what I tell
myself curry spices in it I changed my
mind about the last one that's the one
new idea to take your sausage put a
little cream cheese Oh what is this
motion it's a game like forfeit like
surrender just blew my own mind
haha you were just pairing everything
with sausages and saying that it's good
it's I'm not wrong time to change pace a
little yeah we got a hot cheese dip oh
[Music]
it's dinky no I was thinking is a good
way yeah yeah
Sydney fish market stinky you know one
of those seagulls waiting to come down
and attack the cheese got some big stuff
coming up so I think we need to take a
salad break halftime show need some
roughage every football party that I go
to the real hero who's the person that
brings the salad why is that your body's
gonna thank you later
Oh pork cut up like a cinnamon roll
let's get some mashed potatoes - potato
- oh my god it was oh
crisp like a vegetable on the outside
yeah but then when you got into it it
you just sunk into this hunk of juicy
pork meat and you know what the ultimate
has to be you take a little sausage oh
my gosh and you get your mashed potatoes
and it's like a pig in a blanket
but instead of a blanket
a cloud no I get it
only is every anything the sausage is
really damn good I think I rest my case
[Music]
this has been worth it the Super Bowl
edition Super Bowl is the greatest most
epic game of the year the most epic day
of eating of the air which ultimate
gameday food was most worth to you I
just give him price point
revival chicken fried chicken in your
mouth gee-ya done my worth the winner
goes to chow girls that's how you into a
game day you have it at your house you
can put your friends over everybody pigs
out on whatever they want sorry cowgirl
please Charles well ciao girls that's
why watching the game and eating good
food thanks for watching this game day
special we are gonna be coming back at
you with a season for almost a full
turkey wait how that works that's how
that works
yeah it's gonna be great coming very
soon I can't announce the date yet
because that's gonna be announced on the
trailer get ready oh oh yes